[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nouveaux numéros de mode
d'emploi une édition consacrée aux
conséquences de la crise du coc vie de
10,9 sur l'emploi et la situation des
formations dans le département tout de
suite
le sommaire c'est une augmentation
historique du chômage dans le
département le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi sans activité a augmenté de 10
7% en avril 2020 une forte hausse à
cause de la crise sanitaire
alors que le service de pôle emploi se
réorganise après le déconfinement nous
ferons le point avec hachmi d'amarrer
directeur territorial de pôle emploi
dans les yvelines le déconfinement
synonyme de reprise en présentiel pour
certaines formations
c'est le cas du campus de l'automobile
et de la mobilité à guyancourt des
règles sanitaires ont été mises en place
nous verrons aussi que d'autres
formations se poursuivent à distance
enfin ne nous intéresserons à
l'alternance et aux relations entre les
centres de formation et les entreprises
dans un contexte de crise économique et
sur la préparation de la rentrée 2020 on
commence avec ce constat la hausse
historique du chômage partout en france
à cause de la crise sanitaire dans les
yvelines le nombre de personnes sans
activité inscrits à pôle emploi a
augmenté de 10 7% en avril 2020 c'est du
jamais vu depuis 1996
pour en parler nous sommes avec hachmi
la marie bonjour bonjour alors avant de
parler du déconfinement des services de
pôle emploi
un mot sur le confinement comment s'est
passée cette période dans les services
de pôle emploi dans les yvelines
bâtiment là les deux mois de confinement
était une occasion de nous organiser
autrement pour maintenir les services de
pôle emploi essentiellement à distance
se faire exclusivement à distance
pendant la période des débuts mois nous
avons assuré les activités essentielles
qui était d'inscrire les nouveaux
demandeurs d'emploi de d'assurer leur
actualisation de démons d'emplois et de
et de payer en fin de relais de leurs
indemnités donc et accompagner les
entreprises dans leurs dans le
recrutement notamment sur les métiers et
sur les secteurs essentiels
cette mission a été menée à bien et avec
beaucoup de succès sur les deux mois qui
viennent de se passer
plus de 80 minutes 90 % des demandeurs
d'emploi se sont actualisés 98 % des
demandeurs d'emploi qui en habitude de
s'actualiser en valeur en agence ont été
contactés se sont actualisés et pour les
paiements été réalisée pendant cette
période alors le déconfinement a
commencé le 11 mai comment se sont
organisés les services de pôle emploi
face à cette situation notamment sur
saint quentin en yvelines dans les
yvelines mais effectivement dans les
agences de saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
principe
le premier principe c'est effectivement
un des confirmant une reprise des
activités en présentiel à partir du 18
mai et ont de manière progressive d'eau
dans le respect des règles sanitaires
nous gardons essentiellement nos
activités il comptera l idée en
télétravail et en disque en ciel
de la même manière que pendant la
période de confinement néanmoins toutes
les activités en présentiel nécessaires
notamment les inscriptions lors la
reprise des inscriptions des mots
d'ordre les entretien d'inscription les
accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
qui sont en difficulté avec le numérique
cette activité a repris depuis dix tués
les demandeurs d'emploi peuvent se
présenter en agence l'organisation qu'on
a mis en place pour un respect lui
faisait des flux et des règles de
sanitaires à se passe tout se passe par
hambourg pour cette première étape
nous n'avons repris aussi les activités
liés à l'accompagnement des entreprises
sur les recrutements et nous nous allons
déployer toutes les actions nécessaires
pour à une reprise de nos activités en
présentiel
mais d'une manière très progressive nous
avons quelques projets à mener en terme
en terme de contacts de demandeurs
d'emploi activement pour les sur les
métiers ont assuré qu'elles en pensent
que la reprise d'activité dès la reprise
d'activité on aura besoin d'eux on avait
des gens pour en parler en contact avec
des toutes les entreprises qui avaient
des offres avec nous avant confinement
qu'on a repris avec lesquels 1 a repris
le contact dès cette semaine avec une
avec des offres d'emploi qui sont déjà
récolté par me conseiller merci achemine
à marie
merci à vous le directeur territorial de
pôle emploi dans les yvelines s'informer
sur son projet professionnel passe aussi
par la cité des métiers de saint quentin
en yvelines
la structure a rouvert ses portes
partiellement au public et a dû
s'organiser pour respecter les gestes
barrière dans les prochaines semaines
elle va proposer également un programme
d'ateliers en visioconférence le
reportage d' or ils iront aux jeux après
deux mois de fermeture la cité des
métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
située à trappes vient de rouvrir
partiellement ses portes
gels hydro alcooliques ou encore vitre
en plastique ont été installés pour
accueillir de nouveau le public un
accueil seulement sur rendez vous
pendant le confinement la structure a dû
se réorganiser et a poursuivi ses
entretiens conseils par téléphone dans
la première période le public jeune
puisque on était encore dans la période
parcours sub qui n'avait plus d'endroit
où aller pour se faire aider
les cio et les et les bus relais bij
bureau information jeunesse est enfermé
sont revenus vers la cité des métiers et
ensuite le gros des demandes c'était
vraiment sur l'emploi et sur des projets
de reconversion et ensuite des demandes
dead sur la création d'entreprise au
total plus de 50 entretiens ont été
réalisés afin de poursuivre sa mission
d'information sur les projets
professionnels la cité des métiers va
mettre en place des ateliers en
visioconférence une vingtaine de
partenaires a répondu présent l'idée
c'était de voir
de maintenir ce lien avec les
partenaires et de voir ce qu'on pouvait
mettre en place pendant cette période
spéciale quand même comme atelier comme
qu on me conseille à distance de cette
réunion dont qui on a eu pas mal de
partenaires de cette réunion en est
sortie une programmation qui remplace la
programmation qu'on avait prévu jusque
jusqu'en juillet donc là on a une
nouvelle programmation d'ateliers
collectifs à distance à partir du 2 juin
plus de 25 ateliers sont proposés au
public autour de plusieurs thématiques
création d'activités bilan de
compétences ou encore savoir comment
gérer son stress
le déconfinement du 11 mai 2020 a permis
la reprise de plusieurs formations
professionnelles en présentiel c'est le
cas notamment pour certains jeunes en
apprentissage sur le campus de
l'automobile et de la mobilité à
guyancourt exemple au sein de l'institut
national du cycle et du motocycle avec
les apprentis de ces apps est en
deuxième année
les images sont signés michael et demi
d'euros ils ont repris les cours le 18
mai dernier
ces apprentis en 2e année de ces apps et
maintenance motocycles font partie des
élèves de l'institut national du cycle
et du motocycle à avoir repris leur
formation en présentiel au déconfinement
ils sont une quarantaine de jeunes de
l'établissement sur la centaine
accueilli habituellement qu'on a fait le
choix en fait de prioriser les publics
qui doivent passer leur certification
leur diplôme cette année parce qu'en
effet il ya eu quand même du retard sur
les cours même si on a fait
l'enseignement à distance et parce qu'il
ya un gros enjeu de certification et
d'obtention du diplôme achats de douze
mille masques gel hydroalcoolique
utilisation de gand et suppression des
espaces collectifs des heures de rang
très différente des horaires de pause
avec un quart d'heure de décalage un
plan pensé depuis mi avril pour faire
respecter les gestes barrière après deux
mois de cours à distance en
visioconférence même quand on fait des
démonstrations
en visio c'est pas eux qui pratiquent
ces peuples qui manipulent les outils ni
les pièces du coup il ya forcément un
peu de pertes niveau pratique on a
essayé d'adapter le programme en fait
deux
faire en sorte qu'on puisse leur
apporter le plus de connaissances
possibles dans le laps de temps du coup
qui a été réduit donc ils ont un peu
plus d'heure d'ateliers ils font fait en
sorte d'avoir des programmes peut-être
un peu plus chargé mais d'être plus à
l'écouté en fait de leurs attentes et de
leurs demandes
par exemple sur une semaine le lundi le
mardi et le jeudi peuvent être consacrés
aux enseignements généraux puis des
cours en ateliers sont prévus le
mercredi et le vendredi
un retour au sein de l'établissement
bien accueillis par les élèves
le fait de écouter son professeur parler
à distance même voir des schémas et ça
ça nous permet quand même pas de
pratiques et donc ouais c'est compliqué
et il a juste avec l'école ça change un
petit peu avant on faisait trois jours
d'école avec après on va les deux
derniers jours au travail
là maintenant on fait des semaines
complètes pour rattraper un petit peu
leur part une à deux semaines de cours
ont été rajoutés pour compenser la
période du confinement
la formation devrait se terminer le 10
juillet prochain
la ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire
elisabeth borgne a annoncé le 14 mai
dernier la création d'une académie des
métiers du vélo dans le cadre de ce
programme l'institut national du cycle
et du motocycle va lancer sur le site de
guyancourt une formation de mécanicien
vélo une session du 22 juin au 17
juillet 2020 ouverte pour tout public
demandeur d'emploi ou salariés en
reconversion
ecoutez jean le naour directeur de
l'institut national du cycle et du
motocycle break à des métiers du vélo en
fait elle est née d'une réflexion la
base entre lienz et m et le groupe
cyclable sur le besoin en fait en
personnel plus nombreux au sein donc des
structures existant sous de nouvelles
structures pour aider à
agir est une incitation la fois de
l'état ou des collectivités
territoriales à faire ressortir les bons
vieux vélos de vous-même de moi-même et
de les faire rouler à nouveau on a vu
devant cette urgence qu'il fallait créer
un cursus de formation extrêmement court
on l'a bâtie sur un programme de 20
jours direction elancourt où l'organisme
simple on a dû s'adapter durant le
confinement sur le site de formation
intensive sont dispensés développeurs
web et développeurs data des courts
réalisés à distance
l'occasion pour les formateurs
d'augmenter les suivis individuels et
d'être encore plus à l'écouté des 43
apprenantes et apprenants les stages
prévus pendant la formation ont
également dû se faire à distance un
enseignement en ligne qui pour l'instant
se poursuit jusqu'à nouvel ordre
écoutez on a une task force qui est
mobilisé 1 sur ce sujet là pour que tous
que la reprise éventuelle du présentiel
se passe dans les meilleures conditions
on a déjà commencé bien évidemment les
aspects pratiques à faire des commandes
notamment au niveau du gel
hydroalcoolique pour les passages de
deux titres professionnels et de
certification on espère que ça pourra
être en présentiel c'est vraiment pas
forcément notre préférence pour
l'instant on n'a pas de garantie sur sur
les modalités donc on attend de même
d'en savoir plus pour pouvoir informer
nos apprenants et apprenantes durant la
période de confinement les étudiants en
alternance ont subi les conséquences sur
leurs activités en entreprise parfois
placés en activité partielle avec le
contexte de crise économique comment les
entreprises vont se saisir de
l'apprentissage
on fait le point avec michael etienne
responsable du pôle formation au cfa
l'école connecté au futur de l'industrie
basé à montigny le bretonneux
pendant les périodes écoles tous les
jeunes ont été mis en enseignement à
distance
ça a été possible de le faire pour une
raison assez simple c'est qu'on avait
déjà entamé l'enseignement à distance
avant cette période de confinement liés
aux qu'ovide les jeunes qui étaient en
entreprise eux continuer les entreprises
sauf si les entreprises les ont mis en
chômage partiel
mais même s'ils étaient en chômage
partiel il avait quand même la
possibilité sur les périodes d'école de
suivre l'enseignement à distance à
partir de chez eux
comme on avait du matériel dans l'école
on a prêté du matériel aux jeunes juste
avant la période de confinement
la période de j'allais dire de
d'enseignement à distance pendant le
confinement s'est très bien déroulé
c'est à dire qu'on a eu un taux de
décrocheurs qui était au maximum à 5 %
et en fait qui n'est pas supérieur au
nombre de jeunes qui décrochent
lorsqu'on a des cours en présentiel
donc on a maintenu le dispositif
d'enseignement à distance jusqu'à la fin
de l'année scolaire
la seule chose que l'on a fait c'est
qu'on a des étudiants notamment en
master en robotique pour qui il était
impératif de pouvoir terminer leurs
projets sur cette fin d'année pour ces
jeunes
on a mis en place par des petits groupes
de six personnes
la possibilité de réserver la bonne
robotique deux jours par semaine pendant
trois semaines et cela sur la période de
fin juin
on a de nouveau sollicité fortement les
entreprises pour recruter des jeunes et
on a mis en place un job dating virtuel
à la place de celui qu'on aurait mis en
présentiel
on mettra cette opération sur la période
du 25 juin au vu de la réussite de
l'enseignement à distance pendant cette
période de confinement comment on va
prolonger de façon à ce moment-là plus
structuré et plus organisationnel
l'enseignement à distance donc
actuellement on est en train d'étudier
ce qu'on appelle les plans de formation
où on revoit la proportion
d'enseignement à distance et
d'enseignants en présentiel qui sera mis
en place à partir de la rentrée
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis édition a retrouvé en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]